[Music]
let's do this boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Saki and very excited to be talking
about the digital twin of the planet we
have mark Johnson joining us hello
hello thank you so much for coming on
the show my pleasure
super excited for this episode we are
just gonna be talking about one of I
think the most beautiful things our
beautiful planet that we all get to
share and reside on and some of the most
gorgeous imagery and analyzing its so
pumped for this Mark Johnson for those
who don't know is co-founder and CEO of
decart labs which is a data refinery
built to understand the planet and you
find the links in the bio below to Karl
Abscam as well as the Twitter medium and
also Mark's Twitter as well let's start
things off with our favorite questions
to ask our guests what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world I mean I
think where I think things are getting
better right like you look at things
like global poverty and it's plummeting
access to water disease right like just
things are getting better from a macro
level and that makes me really happy
because it wasn't clear when I was a kid
that things were going in that direction
I still worried about global
thermonuclear war when I was a little
tot and now we worry about that far less
so I think things are going in the right
direction
we're all super computers in our pockets
- that's kind of neat yeah yeah it's the
the spiral upward is very very powerful
and it's the evolution of society well I
like so I live through the PC internet
mobile right like that's a three massive
revolutions that like I was on the
frontlines of and I think all of those
give me a lot of hope like I'll never
forget the first thing that I accessed
on the internet that I brought in to a
teacher in high school I remember
looking down at it looking
me looking down at it looking at me
saying where did you get this and now
everybody has access to free information
and I think the effects of that on
society could be decades down the road
but all positive yeah yeah what it what
is being hat what is happening to the
actual minds of youth that are being
born into a world with access to
querying the human knowledge at their
fingertips moment moment to moment is
doing some beautiful stuff I wanna
let's hit let's hit on the journey I'm
born in Agra Falls who who were you when
you were growing up and how did you get
interested in the fields that you got
passionate about I mean I was I was a
pretty nerdy kid probably unsurprisingly
I read a lot my mother and I we used to
go to a library with a stack of books on
Saturday and we would come out with
another stack of books oh we just read
read read and I think that helped a lot
like I got really interested in
volcanoes and really is interested in
not really archaeology but sort of
ancient gods and belief systems when I
was a kid so I had all these really
really weird interests and I got a
computer when I were from fairly humble
means but I got a computer also early on
and that was really neat right because
it wasn't just it wasn't just a video
gaming system right it was a system that
you could actually manipulate and I'm I
was and I am a terrible programmer but I
used to type in programs from magazines
that would come in the mail and that
teaches you a little bit about like
about how the underlying thing works
right it's not just this magic box that
that shows you pretty pictures there's
actually a lot of mechanics that that go
into that I think that really influenced
me a lot too so yeah you know those are
big ones or big ones and then what about
the transition into philosophy first at
Stanford yeah like I well I was a
terrible student at first and I thought
was gonna be a math major because I was
in this math program and Buffalo is
pretty neat they pulled us out of math
class starting in seventh grade and sent
us to university so I thought I was good
at math
until I got to Stanford and realized it
like I was good at math and Buffalo not
so much in in at Stanford and then I
thought computer science because it was
1997 it turns out I'm a terrible
programmer so I left for a few years or
for a year about 18 months and I spent
time in PR and this was during the
Internet boom and it was absolutely
crazy to like just watch companies much
like today it's like you go from zero to
getting bought by AOL and in 12 months
and when I came back I thought well it
doesn't really matter what I study I'm
just gonna go out and do something in
technology anyway and one of my first
classes was a philosophy class mine
matter and meaning and I got a c-minus
on my first paper and I has actually
worked hard on that one so I was really
unhappy so I went into the TA and she
explained why it was wrong and I totally
got hooked because philosophy forces you
to ask questions about things that
people don't normally ask questions
about oh what is true what is meaning
how do people understand each other and
those are really really tough questions
and I still don't have the answers to
any of them but it's fun to think about
yeah yeah every child would have an
excellent I think experience having to
go block themselves through those types
of questions that's that's huge okay and
then and then so then there was a
trajectory of like about like almost 15
years or so of time until decart really
came up for you then what was kind of
the moment for you were the moments for
you that that triggered your desire to
want to work in this field well I I
really liked seeing technology come out
into the real world and the two startups
before Descartes were both spinouts from
labs so powerset was a spin out of Xerox
PARC so it was natural language
technology really a decade before Siri
and probably way too early and then my
company before that site was it's been
out of University of British Columbia it
took years before we could figure out
how to use that technology and turn it
in
to a product so after so I sold site to
CNN ran it within CNN for a while and
when I left my plan was actually I was
thinking like it would be cool to just
wander the halls of Carnegie Mellon and
Stanford and Berkeley and see if I could
find some really smart grad student PhDs
who had some crazy technology and do
something with it and I got a call from
scientists at Los Alamos National
Laboratory and I'd read a biography of J
robert Oppenheimer when I was in high
school and I was like this is this whole
project the Manhattan Project is the
greatest science and engineering project
of all time I mean is just phenomenal
the number of brilliant minds that
worked on it the fact that we were able
to get it done you know effects
notwithstanding it's just astonishing we
were able to do that in such a short
amount of time so when I got a call from
the scientist I said heck iam going out
to New Mexico and I didn't really have
any expectations and when I met them I
was blown away by how smart they were
blown away by some of the things that
they showed me and I I just took the
leap and I had no idea where I was going
to end up but I ended up in New Mexico
whoa it was so it was a big kind of like
aha of like they're so much data that
needs to be refined from imaging the
earth yeah okay yeah yeah I mean these
guys are so like what's amazing about a
place like Los Alamos is that in
addition to being stewards of the
National nuclear stockpile there's a lot
of blue sky research that goes on there
and one of the things I think we all
recognize as we were spinning out is
that the way science is done is
fundamentally changing so moving from a
world where we sample small populations
and do statistical analysis on those
small samples to world where we
continuously monitor things I think the
output of that is call it some kind of
digital twin of the phenomenon right so
like if we want to do we want to do
better drug testing be really cool if
you had some sort of simulation in a
computer you had some virtual humans to
test on before you actually test it in
real humans in our case building a
digital twin of the planet I certainly
don't want to run AV tests on the earth
told we might screw that up
I would much rather run those in a
simulation and understand these systems
digitally before we could go test them
in the real world so the recognition was
if you want to do science like that or
if you want to build these these complex
models it requires enormous enormous
amounts of data and even the datasets
that we're looking at today on the
petabyte scale you expect that those
datasets are gonna get bigger and bigger
and bigger so what does that mean so
you've got these sensors that represent
changes in the world and you want to
make predictions about the future so you
need some place to pull in all this data
you need to access it really quickly you
need to be able to throw almost an
infinite amount of compute against it
and then you can start to build these
digital twins so I think that was like
the core recognition at the beginning of
the company and kind of you know how we
started thinking about the world and
because of that aspect to your worldview
this is why I love you so much you are
pioneering what I think is that digital
twin phenomena that is about to just be
way more common in our world of viewing
things that way you gave the example of
Medicine you'd much rather simulate what
it's actually going to happen when you
take a pharmaceutical to a human's body
before they actually take it there's so
many examples of this in engineering
simulation of healthcare simulation and
planetary simulation actually seeing
what how a civilization involves how its
impacted by making uh certain variable
changes I love this this is this is one
of the best ways I think to look at and
just like you're saying simulations all
the way up and all the way down to right
like if you think about simulating a
human body like you probably want to
simulate the cells you want to simulate
organs you want to simulate the body oh
by the way bodies are part of society so
you want to simulate how humans interact
right like I think that what's neat
about this if you really want to kind of
take it to its fullest is that you know
you get richer and richer models of how
the world works and richer and richer
models in silico
than testing all this stuff out in the
real world so I mean ultimately you just
want to build these simulations I mean
the reason that a lot of technology
companies are good is because they do
these a B test because they test things
against each other
and it's just really hard to do that in
the real world there's this world is
finite whereas what we can do in a
computer is infinite especially if you
can model it and that's super exciting
yes and I'm excited to get to the
technicals with you on exactly how
you're doing that let's let's get into
some of the some of the craziness that
we've been experiencing so this is the
camp fire yeah probably a few hours
after ignition this is the camp fire I
mean there's how horrible is that that's
when it's small relatively so yeah this
is taken from space satellite called
Landsat eight probably taken some hours
after ignition and you know what a
horrible fire that was 82 people died
something around that yeah were the
numbers like I don't know 250 square
miles something like that was destroyed
so I mean it's just a it was a horrible
fire and we have to monitor this stuff
better right like we need to understand
why these fires start we have to better
understand what to do when they start
you know one of the things that we're
trying to build is an automatic wildfire
detectors so globally you can go see a
wildfire after it starts right away
because the sooner you know about it
this you know you can go take action but
yeah it's it's pretty scary and you can
use thermal detection and optical
detection so there's I think it was the
the previous slide had that yeah this
was the thermal detection yeah exactly
so I mean obviously very grainy but you
can start to see well what do you mean
by see here right so what we're seeing
is sort of like an analysis right really
the the thermal bands and seeing the
actual like heat of the fire started
whereas the other picture is natural
picture kind of like
we think about it yeah but I mean that's
what's exciting about this is that you
can start to use these different types
of data combine them together you just
get this much much richer picture of
what's happening down there yes and so
this is even we're gonna be going
through so many of these examples they
all tie in as a continuous record of the
earth of monitoring the earth and you
said the scientific paradigm transition
of instead of doing these small little
case studies on people is now like
having the sensors in the internet of
things in the constant data stream that
needs to be refined and have predictable
insights about the future I'd love
transitions massive yeah I mean actually
when I was a kid I used to play this
game called sim earth so there's Sim
City of course but there was another
game called simearth the goal is to like
grow from single-cell well from plants
to single-celled creatures to ultimately
get some sort of sentient life and then
you win and it was fun we started the
company I really thought about that a
lot like we kind of want to make a
simearth and what's neat is that we've
been collecting data about the planet
from satellites that's publicly
available since 1972 that was pretty
smart that we started doing that so yeah
there's this Landsat eight yeah so
Landsat one went up in 1972 was this
what this is one no I think this is
probably a this is okay okay one went up
in 1972 yeah so there's been seven that
functioned one didn't quite work okay
but that means you have a continuous
record back through that set of
satellites these are US taxpayer dollars
through NASA that's correct okay and
also a really important event happened a
little over a decade ago where we've
made those images free so that's been
great because it means that the Landsat
archive is free a number of the other
NASA satellites is freely available and
then the European Space Agency is they
started putting up Earth observation
satellites also have made their data
free and this is great right because
this is a public good which one is this
oh that is a sentinel that sentinel a
sentient one okay yeah so that's not the
ESA yeah so this is a European Space
Agency satellite
what's neat about this there's two of
them and their radar satellites so
Landsat is you know mostly optical where
it's like a camera the light bounces off
and it gets picked up by the sensor this
is an active sensor so it's like a bat
it shoots out a beam of radar it bounces
off of stuff and then it's picked up by
the satellite which is already pretty
neat and it means it sees in a different
kind of way so one of the things that
you look for is how much of the signal
comes back to the satellite so if you
hit water a ton of the signal is
reflected back because it's highly
reflective if you hit a forest where
there's deciduous trees full of leaves
then a lot of that scatters so not
nearly as much and the signal goes bad
so what you can do with these satellites
is kind of see they're really good at
seeing changes so for example if you
have a bunch of trees and then you don't
have a bunch of trees you can sort of
see that change with a satellite so on
it's this whole new modality oh another
neat thing about it is that the radar
the wavelengths are long enough that
they pass through clouds
so in really cloudy areas you don't have
to worry about the clouds as much and we
find often combining the optical where
you actually see what's going on with
the radar where you sort of see in a
different way again creates this much
much richer picture this is a common
theme when you're thinking about data
and doing science on data is there's no
one data source that solves all your
problems oftentimes you need to combine
a bunch of different data sources in
order to get that sort of scientific
picture yes yes man stacking optical
stacking radar you can now you can
really start realizing why this is
taking like petabytes of data and wool
well I mean you go all the way from the
sky to the ground to I mean think of
like you know a plane flying over the
Atlantic is throwing off hundreds of
terabytes of data like cars would throw
off a lot of data like you know we've
got sensors on our wrists like
everything is being out
fitted with a sensor now and that means
that you have all this data about things
moving around you know pictures being
taken from space you have drones an
aerial flying so more and more just the
world is getting outfitted with these
sensors which means that basically we'll
have the data to create a complete
picture of everything that's happening
on the planet and it's funny I don't see
that as creepy I see that as more I see
it from a very scientific viewpoint
right that this is important to do
because we want to be good stewards of
the planet well I guess there's a creepy
aspect to it also yeah whoever's in
charge of this advanced technology that
gets up that gets a perfect sensor
viewpoint of everything that's happening
on the planet at the same time yeah well
but it also makes us better stewards if
you think that we're gonna have a lot of
examples in here that that are gonna
further push that along I really like
how you explained that thats our
synthetic aperture radar yes is able to
penetrate clouds because half of the
planet has clouds at it at any time
which at least there's an interesting
stat you can see damage after hurricanes
easier okay and then these are these the
geostationary once one of them is I part
two very oh yeah I mean they're all sort
of covered in foil it looks like no so
there's another satellite this is neat
we're using it for this is good a lot of
different things but wildfires
it's called goes so there's been a whole
series of these also so these are
meteorological satellites so like when
you see a hurricane like twirling in the
Atlantic it's this satellite but what's
neat about it is it's geostationary so
the other two are what they call push
brooms so they're kind of constantly
going around the planet taking pictures
taking pictures taking pictures so as
the planet rotates ultimately you get a
full picture of the planet during some
time period
I think the Landsat satellites are each
16 days for example 16 day orbital
period they do you get a complete
picture of the globe every 16 days
there's all of them
still 90 minute orbital ish that's what
the ISS is something well yeah but so
these are these are just basically they
fly there they're flying over the planet
is and and they're taking pictures
constantly yeah and you get a strip and
that goes around you get another strip
and you get another strip and ultimately
once you get all those strips you after
you get all a complete picture of the
planet this just sort of sits up there
and just takes a picture every five
minutes now the resolution isn't great
right like you're not like getting
geostationary geostationary and you're
not getting a really high resolution so
like sometimes the the pixels are like a
kilometer squared all right but what you
do get is a complete picture of the
continental United States every five
minutes and that's really useful if you
want to do something like wildfires and
you want to detect them in real time you
can't wait for a week until the
satellite passes it's too late you need
something that's constantly taking
pictures so what we do is we pull the
images off of the satellite and they're
ready in the system to be analyzed in
about four minutes so you have to like
you know do some fancy footwork to make
sure that the data is available and
ready okay so you're getting data
sources from landsat's that are in orbit
every 16 days that are taking full
images of the earth and that includes
the side of the earth that's dark versus
the side of the earth that's light so
you see some of light pollution maybe
you're doing things like closing the
aperture a bit when you're on the dark
side like how is that working for
optical imaging one year well so there's
there's a night light satellite so you
can see night light also satellite yeah
Vere's but okay but but all this is the
Sun reflecting off the planet yeah so
it's it's best if the Sun is actually
shining but yes what's neat about this
is that we have so many different
sources of data to draw upon so you have
you know satellites that are imaging the
connell United States 3 5 minutes you
have modis which is 2 satellites aqua
and Terra that they image the entire
globe every day
again not a great resolution but you
still get this continuous monitoring you
have Landsat which you know effectively
is a say bi-weekly you have the
sentinels
which they have several different series
from European Space Agency doing radar
doing optical doing daily so you've got
all these data sets so we pull in
somewhere around the order of like 10 to
15 terabytes of new data a day we've
about 15 petabytes of data in the
archive and again a lot of this is
publicly available this was this was
actually a big shocker when we started
the company because I really didn't know
about satellite so I started studying
them and turns out we have these massive
records of data and yet people can't
answer basic questions about the planet
how much food is growing on the planet
how much food is growing in Brazil how
many trees have we cut down on in the
Amazon to the tree and the fact that we
couldn't answer these questions even
though we had the data made me scratch
my head a little bit and again this is
sort of the foundation of the company is
you ought to be able to answer those
basic questions about the planet yes yes
okay so you're getting the the constant
stream of images of the planet of both
the from both satellites that are
orbiting satellites that are
geostationary optical radar and then you
have to do things like had come up with
these insights you have to refine the
data come up with these insights and
make them valuable to people that the
people want to know about these that of
the above these insights well one thing
you want to do is make sure that you
just have access to all this imagery
right if you think about it if you want
to do a big analysis through time it
means that you let's the corn belt in
the u.s. is three million square
kilometers so if you want to know how
much food is growing this corn belt and
you want to monitor it while the food is
growing it means you look need to look
at those three million square kilometers
every single day while the growing
season is happening that's a lot of data
so partly what the system does is the
data refinery does is pull in all the
data clean it up but then you have to
make it accessible to people so you need
a really fast API that could go pull all
those images out stitch them all
together do some analysis on it and that
just
doing that and that's why it's why you
need to build a supercomputer in the
cloud because it's a it's a tough task
you had an interesting story with the
corn as well where you were get you were
getting the insights that like every
like four days compared to the USDA
which was only giving like corn insights
around the planet every month and then
you kind of decided that you wanted to
be a date a refinery company and kind of
potentially be doing this more for all
different types of data interest rather
than siloing yourself into like corn
yeah I think what's interesting when you
go back and look at the early days of
the company is like you're always
putting the lens of how you think about
the world today so honestly it wasn't
all this was not as obvious to us at the
time but looking back on it it kind of
was so we did the exact wrong thing that
you're not supposed to do we started off
with the technology and figured out the
market they tell you and startup land
not to do that right like figure out the
market figure out the problem and then
apply technology to that problem totally
not how we did it so we decided that we
wanted to understand the planet we said
well what are we gonna do so the first
thing we decided to do was agriculture
and one of the reasons is just it fits
the data set so cornfields are big corn
grows relatively slowly and corn doesn't
wander around so like you can keep
observing those fields every day so the
data sets are really well mapped and
then this goes and maps back to my
assertion about how science is changing
so the way the USDA during the growing
season understands or tries to forecast
how much corn has come out of the ground
and billions of bushels of corn is they
go talk to farmers they go to fields
they go count kernels of corn so they
sample a small set of data and then they
a bunch of statisticians who sit in a
room for 10 days then on the 12th of the
month the the
announced what they've done they're like
why I do that when you can look at every
cornfield every day as long as there's
not a cloud there I can look at the
field so that's what we did so in the
first nine months of the company we
built this corn production forecast for
the US it was very accurate you can see
the corn changing everyday you can zoom
in to the county level and when we
released the he released the number on
Bloomberg we moved the price of corn 3%
that day yeah and this was like a shock
to people who follow corn in the Midwest
because we weren't agronomists this is a
bunch of physicists who didn't have any
special knowledge of corn we just
treated the corn like little factories
and were able to understand what their
output was and get a really accurate
model and that same thing is being done
for soybeans for we're going to talk
about like deforestation we're talk
about actually counting the trees around
the plane we're going to talk about all
these different ways of monitoring the
exact like yields of crops how much food
is growing on the plane all these types
of really important questions ok see you
guys are in Santa Fe your team's grown
quite a bit now we talked about some of
this stuff the data refinery side of
things this is a really applicable
explanation of how like an engine that
we're really familiar with this you're
like Facebook engine or your Google
engine where you're actually the data
that is being refined about your search
queries and then then it's a tailoring
to you same thing with your news feeds
your videos on Netflix your purchase on
Amazon I think that's a good way to get
kind of like data refining overtime
towards personalized habits yeah I mean
like all these companies like the
Amazons and the Facebook's like Amazon
takes huge amounts of purchased data and
they predict what you want to buy Google
predicts what you wanted to search for
or Facebook predicts what you want to
read and they can do this because they
have all this data not just about you
but these external data sets like
products and webpages and whatnot see I
I've kind of recast the world as a data
refinery I like that a lot that's a you
I think you're the first one that
introduced me to the term data refinery
and I like that a lot
we're not finding the data
it's like an observation like I worked
for a bunch of unsuccessful search
companies right I didn't work for Google
and I had all these theories at the time
like why Google was better and there's a
few reasons one is that their data set
was just better they have a much cleaner
better data set there so they spent a
lot of time and things like spam another
reason is that they had a better
laboratory for their scientists is not
just that their scientists were more
clever is that they could try more
at-bats right they can go experiment
real time they can go push an algorithm
live and see what the effects are they
were just really good at measuring it so
that you know that's kind of the
inspiration for the company is how to
create that laboratory for scientists to
go try a lot of things when we were
built the original corn model we tried
over a thousand candidate models so
that's a lot of data that you need to
push through those models to test how
good they are so yeah the
it's it's like when you have a a a like
like you give this example of when you
were in the process of working at search
companies and you could see that another
company was doing things this is kind of
like what's potentially gonna happen
like digital twins as well who can make
the most effective simulations of a
digital twin of the planet because
you're not gonna want to be b tests on
the planet that is not as well simulated
as the other organization that has a
better simulation of the planet so
that's like it's kind of potentially
going to lead into some dynamic maybe
some oligopoly dine style dynamics we're
the ones that have the best simulations
are gonna get all the business kind of
like the Google and Baidu's are getting
all of the business yeah I mean that's
one of the one of the downsides of data
refinery as a model is it's really hard
to break it so look at Bing right we had
really good scientists we were building
a decent laboratory to go kind of build
better ranking engines what we didn't
have was a decade of user data so
there's this data flywheel that starts
to happen where facebook knows what you
want to read because they know what
you've read in the past and they have
this huge population of people who have
read things so now they know what
content to put in front of you that has
the highest chance of you interacting
with it which means it's really hard for
someone to break into that market and I
think this is one of the hallmarks of
the data driven companies is that if
they get really good at that feedback
loop it's really hard to break it and
then there's there's other effects you
like look at Netflix where they realized
that not only were they a good
recommendation engine to recommend
someone else's content turns out they
could build a whole new business on top
of it because they knew so well what you
watched they could go build shows based
on your viewing preferences rather than
your demographics or rather than your
psychographics and that was kind of a
mind-blowing leap I think in content
production yes it reminds these
companies that they're not just search
engines or social networks there's
probably other businesses they could
build on top of it you know could be
good could be scary yeah
you know the building businesses on top
of the data that they were finding
because they get the really valuable
insights and then it'll be interesting
to see where the dynamics move okay
let's hit the team's up to like 100
people now that's massive
congratulations it seems growing super
fast I know it's a kid I always wanted
to have a lab of scientists and now
there's a whole Lab of scientists in New
Mexico I thought were gonna be
underground but we're actually in an
office oh man this is cool yeah I love
this one okay so this is no.2 yep okay
so this is a new satellite that went up
from the European Space Agency and what
it does is it monitors greenhouse gases
so it's sort of the first we're almost
like prototype satellite and what this
is this is not a visual view of the
world but this is monitoring is no.2 and
that's largely burning things so it
doesn't stay around for very long but
it's very visible so as the globe turns
you'll be able to see some really neat
stuff here
excuse me see things like shipping
obviously cities and human activity as a
big contributor but fires are also
contributor you start to see shipping
lanes and you see sort of where the
planes are flying Oh clear the bush in
Africa there's a lot of fires down there
you see the shipping lane from the
Mediterranean down here no India goes
down here all the way to China lipping
Lane yeah right through the South China
Sea around the Indian Ocean yeah yeah so
it's this eerie picture of the world you
start to see human activity well both
human and natural activity from this
different perspective right again we're
not seeing the visual here we're seeing
this invisible gas that is indicative of
different kinds of of activity and you
have teammates that are working on the
different ways of seeing the world
through these different activity
indicators through these different
sensing systems and coming up with
insights about that well and this is
interesting right these this isn't just
concentrations in the atmosphere this is
kind of like locationally where is it
right and there's not there hasn't been
really a global sensor that's been
this so far and this allows us to go
monitor greenhouse gases be able to
pinpoint sources for example there is
the separate there so there's a one that
will measure like methane yeah let's
keep going good a methane this is great
so this is a methane yep so methane is a
fascinating gas ch4 is odorless
colorless and we've learned a lot about
it over the past decades so originally
Matano is about 20 times worse than
carbon dioxide now that that number
keeps getting revised up now it's a do
you think it's about 35 times worse than
carbon dioxide so that's that's bad
right so we should try to reduce methane
emissions the problem is that we don't
really understand the lifecycle you know
if there's cows right like there's also
places like where there's a lot of
fracking so the natural gas is sometimes
vented so you see a lot of methane there
we also see something curious like why
is there so much methane in the Sahara
where there's basically nothing and the
current raining we don't really know to
be clear the current reigning theory
there is that the atmospheric conditions
caused the methane to absorb more energy
in those areas but you know these are
things that we really need to understand
better if we're gonna make sure that we
don't heat up the planet and you know
screw ourselves the fact that you get
and a visual like again this is a piece
of data that it's not like when you're
under gather on the surface that you can
be like oh why is there a vast amount of
methane that's coming out of this air
like it literally requires you to get
this image from satellite imagery and
then then you can pose these questions
and make these unique insights about
about the planet yeah there's a well and
maybe you even this is actually just
night lights but you can see the flaring
in the Permian Basin so you have a few
options with natural gas
that that comes out of a well so your
choices are you just let it go in which
case it just goes up in the atmosphere
you burn it which actually is probably
better than just venting it mainly
because the process what what comes out
of burning is not nearly as bad as the
methane a third of course is to capture
it and use it right so we can use this
natural gas but one thing you might want
to do in these areas where so this is
New Mexico so we have a little part of
the Permian Basin one thing you might
want to do is is fly aerial over these
these areas where there's methane so you
know pinpoint sources another source is
leaks just straight-up leaks in the
pipes so as we get more of this data it
just means we can be better stewards and
understand the effect that we're having
and so we have no2 we have methane then
this is uh this is China yeah and what
is what's happening here so we're trying
to pinpoint like so what you want to do
with this ultimately is you want to
pinpoint sources right so there's sort
of like global scale analysis you can do
a course but one thing you might want to
do is go pinpoint sources of pollution
of the pollution so this is the co2 what
this is ah this I don't remember okay
this man was pinpoint but you want a
pinpoint source of pollution yeah so
again this is not as granular as you
probably want if you wanted to go
pinpoint every Factory on the planet or
every industrial plant on the planet but
again this is if you think about policy
that comes out about reducing carbon
emissions or reducing greenhouse gases
one of the things you need to do is
figure out where it's coming from so you
can go go police those regulations so I
think satellites like this are going to
become critical as we as we can as we
try to get everybody to be more
sustainable yeah we're the biggest
pollution sources across the planet
yeah the amazonian to forestation
ionosphere chemistry also the
phytoplankton x' effect on of the
atmospheric chemistry as well because
it's what oxygenates
a planet this is so important to really
slow down and think about the parts per
million of co2 in the atmosphere yeah
and our planetary health yeah I mean
again I there's so much we know now and
we should use that information to make
smart decisions for the future but we
need to be honest with ourselves that
there's so much we don't know and it's
important to be honest with yourselves
because it means that you direct science
in a certain way and very importantly I
think you direct what data you collect
in a certain way to make sure you can
start to build these models right again
you want to simulate what's going on in
the atmosphere so we don't mess it up
too much yeah so like this is where
forests are really important right
understanding we're where there are
forests and where we've DeForest is is
critically important so this is where
sand if you go a few more oh yeah so
this is this is in Borneo over a few
years and these are all the pictures
taken as you can see when we go a couple
clear shots yeah you can sort of see
what you ought to be seeing here and a
few of those but like you don't see that
very often right so you need a better
way of like especially in these cloudy
areas often times where there's rain
forests these critically endangered
forests you want to be able to see
through the clouds because you're doing
the deforestation detection yep and
that's with synthetic aperture radar SAR
again and it's like with Borneo it's
because of palm trees being cut down for
palm oil yeah there's the deforestation
and Laos for rubber yeah be these types
of yeah palm oil rubber in Brazil often
soy so you know there's all sorts of
reasons why why trees get cut down if
you go to the next one it's neat because
what you can do is you can see it you
can verify an optical you can sort of
see what's happening again this is like
we kind of translate the radar into
something visual that you can see you
know and it kind of pops out and what
you want to do is once you've seen this
see that change happen
and radar you want to go verify it when
you finally get a cloud free shot in the
optical bands you can actually see it
that's what deforestation looks like and
so you can there could literally be a
cloud over the one on the right and
you'd still get that image which is cool
good then yeah you would slowly be
seeing potentially some of the Oh then
there's a processing where you see like
has the left side shut it out an extra
couple centimeters or whatever and then
on the image and then you could know
that oh potentially more trees are being
cut down over time and this is really
important like if you think about cities
like we're awash in data right like
everything from people posting social
media to you know cameras on on lights
on traffic lights just like people
throwing off data cars throwing off data
a lot of the places where natural
resources are produced are places where
they're just not a lot of people Western
Australia produces an enormous amount of
iron ore there's literally almost no one
in Western Australia if you look at the
Corn Belt right about Perth well it's
like North Western Australia there's a
thirst yes but really there's not a lot
there you look at places where food is
grown you look at places where oil is
pumped out of the ground like these are
places with it just not a lot of human
beings so one of the neat things about
satellites is they don't care where
there's humans they're always just
taking pictures so we can start to
monitor these places the earth and start
getting data on place to the earth where
there just isn't a lot of human activity
or you know human data perhaps yes yes
and the scales of this is very
interesting too because this image
you're we're talking like that
centimeter I was talking about on the
image is actually what is that like a
kilometer or look it's like we're
talking like no this is so maybe say 10
to 15 meters per pixel here so somewhere
between 10 and 30 meters 10 isley susi
meters per pixel per pixel that's a
that's okay
yeah yeah look it you're not gonna be
able to see like individual cars right
you're not gonna be able to see
certainly human beings but again you're
kind of looking for these phenomena on
the planet which are much larger in
scale
turns out Natural Resources so
agriculture energy like metals all these
things are really large and you can
actually see at this scale yeah like
this is annual change it in Indonesia
between at 2017 to 2018 start to see
some of these firms pop up yeah Wow it
also makes me like filled earth when I
see this happening because the earth has
an ecosystem that is intertwined and
when that is that directly affects the
insects the animals the plants the soil
compositions the the air cycle I mean it
affects everything is so it's like you
can literally feel the earth change when
we divorced it yeah I know it's really I
think it's really powerful for people at
the company right as you're like as
you're working on a project whether it's
for a company a client or whether you're
doing it you know we're a program
internally called impact science where
people kind of work on their passion
projects but you can't help but like
feel connected back to the planet when
you're doing this and and thinking about
all the changes that we're making like
on one hand it's really important that
we need to sustain society right like
we've got billions of people to feed
they want stuff like we need to make
sure the society is moving forward on
the other hand you need to do so in the
most responsible way and the only way
you start to answer these questions is
by building up the data to create these
highly interconnected systems like you
hit on it like this is not just about
forests disappearing and okay they're
not sucking up as much carbon dioxide
there's whole ecosystems that are on the
ground here that we don't fully
understand we've got to start
understanding how those things all plug
in together and what are the
economic incentives of people in the
regions that are making the decisions of
doing these types of things is there a
way to to have offsets where you can
incentivize people to not do behave this
way but rather to have other means of
getting themselves into a higher
socioeconomic status as that type of
stuff I mean monitoring and tracking are
absolutely critical right so let's say
most companies don't want a source SOI
from former rainforest but how do you go
verify that in some ways you need both a
monitoring system something like
satellites and really need some sort of
tracking system like blockchain or
something like that where you can track
how how these products and goods move
through the system so you can go back
and verify like what if you wanted to do
something like so no-till field so the
ground pulls in an enormous amount of
carbon dioxide and it traps the carbon
dioxide in the soil which is great if
you go till the field if you go plow it
up a lot of that carbon dioxide gets
released
so no-till means that it's sort of like
a minimal tilling process where you
leave a lot of the carbon dioxide in the
ground what if you wanted to go verify
that all of the corn that you source
that fed the chickens so you can say
that your chickens are no-till that's
really hard right now but you need to go
verify back in the system so I think
that some of the technology that's
coming online is going to allow
consumers to make better more
environmentally-friendly choices it's
gonna give companies sort of something
that they can they can brag about how
their how their chicken is more
environmentally friendly but it really
requires a lot of technology and in that
whole process to to both verify on track
you can take directly the data that
you're taking from satellite imaging
and immediately put that on a
decentralized digital ledger that's
immutable and then you can verify if
someone's actually following through on
the indicators that they're claiming
that they're following through on these
types of things love that okay so I want
to hit on do your also things like the
fish farms in Ecuador that can be
monitored over time because fish farming
big when I wanna okay so this is an
investigation into further de for
station leveraging multiple data sources
there's also so not only is a global
watch of deforestation it's also the
early warning system for fire detection
as well yeah that's huge we've had that
image at the very beginning of the
campfire we spent a lot of time thinking
about trees and so actually this is a
great picture this is actually our team
running up one of the highest peaks in
New Mexico they said they're like what's
that cloud over there it turns out it
was a fire so where we lived in New
Mexico is the southern tip of the
Rockies fairly high so Santa Fe is at
7,000 feet and then a bunch of you know
10 11 12 thousand foot mountains there
and it was a really really really dry
year last year like up and there was
almost no snowpack in our mountains by
June there was almost no rain so we were
terrified right like that that we were
gonna have a terrible fire season
luckily the rain started pretty heavily
and we ended up with very few fires in
New Mexico but this inspired us like hey
we've got all this data can we do
something can we can we build an early
warning system so basically what what we
tried to do is use the data from this
ghost satellite that takes pictures
every five minutes to see if we can go
detect forest fires before they were
detected in other ways because there's
all sorts of ways you can go to tech
forest fires so yeah it's pretty neat oh
those are the discs
so here like this is still early right
because you don't want to cry wolf too
much yeah that's no good but continue to
tune it so this is New Mexico and a
little bit of Texas and the yellows are
places that we detected after it was
reported the greens are actually places
where we detected it before reported
yeah which is really neat so again the
early days of this but this should give
us hope right because literally every
minute counts with yes whereas fires and
the difference between a major fire and
a minor fire could be those minutes so
the quicker we can get this in the hands
of the authorities the better live save
property saved yeah absolutely and then
you think about some of the other
implications like can we better
understand fires themselves right like
why do they start how to be spread right
there's there's a lot of implications
right this is you know force our
complicated systems can we better
understand them and then you are also
even going as far as actually of
counting trees as well which i think is
very cool we typically don't even know
and it's hard because you have to you
have to count trees while there's parks
and grass and bushes and also the type
of stuff but you can actually do
interesting things like you can tell
like up there on some of our satellite
imagery is the difference between you
know like Redwood City and Atherton here
in the Bay Area and like there's like a
difference in socioeconomic status and
there's a difference in tree count in
after
yeah yeah again this is where you know
one of the things you do with these
pixel level data sets so a lot of what
we do is just this very very raw data
and you start to add some sort of
semantic content on it right you say
this is a house this is a tree this is a
road now think about starting to overlay
other datasets once I've started counted
a bunch of objects and I kind of know
what's going on on the ground
now what if I look at what if I look at
9-1-1 calls what if I look at asthma
what if I look at median incomes now you
start to layer these different things
and you start to see correlations and as
you build up on those correlations
eventually you can look for causation so
I like this this is work we did counting
trees in the city as you can imagine
well you can't just do is look for green
things because you're going to count a
lot of things that aren't trees and it's
hard to do this even if you wanted to
send out a fleet of humans to do it it's
hard there's private property there's
places they can't get to they can't go
physically count every tree so you kind
of need an automatic system like this so
this was a fun project last summer like
that detecting detectors to count the
trees as well you can also do cool
things like see that parts of our living
areas that don't have and as many trees
yeah I mean it's neat like when you see
in the middle you can see Manhattan
right yeah I mean obviously Central Park
pops out yeah but again it I love these
they're like these negative Maps right
where you're not actually seeing things
you're seeing some phenomenon but out of
that negative image pops out you know
you can see the streets of Manhattan
right like isn't that cool and how big
of a tree desert yes it is a Side
Central Park pretty much yeah and and
then Minneapolis on the left and Miami
on the right mm-hmm okay you get some
really beautiful pictures too yeah that
one's gorgeous Baltimore Baltimore yeah
again you can tell a higher
socio-economic status well also a higher
socioeconomic status but also higher
density right as you can imagine
conversation
yep there's fewer trees in places where
there are lots of buildings but yeah it
really starts again sometimes these
datasets are interesting on their own
it's really cool that you can count the
trees but it's also interesting when you
start combining it with other datasets
so we've got there's actually some folks
in and in Baltimore who are going to
look at this from from a scientific
perspective so use these this tree
dataset and correlate it with some other
datasets so we have some cool stuff
there it's like layering the datasets on
top of each other and to get even more
profound insights I want to I love this
image I want to make sure this one this
is kind of like what your you know your
massive future prediction is around the
the digital twin and all of the data
that we're getting from space the data
that we're getting from the stratosphere
from the air with drones and planes and
then from the ground and subsurface and
like you can literally have all that
data being refined and have insights
that you can predict potentially and
make very high value insights for for
people for organizations for our planet
for being better stewards so this is
huge and I love this well I think it's
neat because it's very rare you get a
business where you can both make money
and do a lot of good and in our case we
can do both like and some in some ways
they really they really marry each other
so as you help companies who like no one
likes to talk about commodities because
they all seem very dirty but you don't
get these higher level products if you
don't mind stuff out of the ground and
pump stuff out of the ground so the
question is how do we make those
industries as sustainable as possible
and to me this is really exciting
because we're basically shining a light
on these supply chains yeah so these
supply chains these commodities have
been producing externalities for decades
but no one can see them no one can see
the methane coming out no one sees the
runoff but you start to measure these
things now these companies are going to
have to deal with those externalities as
part of their business and if I were one
of these companies I would sort
taking taking into my own hands saying
Wow maybe I should actually measure my
effect before governments NGOs the UN
starts to measure it for me and really
become a leader in this space so I think
one of the neat things about lighting up
supply chains it's not just about hey
I'm gonna make more money against my
competitor it's really lighting up
exactly what's happening from from a
pollution and a sustainability
perspective yes and yeah an ethical
perspective yeah we're we're we're
mining the resources from the ground
because we typically only just go and
provide an amount of money for the for
the piece of hardware that we're
purchasing but to actually understand
what's going into it a supply chain
across the world to light that up it's
very beautiful yeah yeah you do want to
explain this is what you're actually be
able to see from one of the land sets
that go every 16 days is that no I
believe this is a satellite called
Discoverer
okay so basically kind of watching
there's a one strip is that on one
stripper is that on the whole thing no
no no this sort of like this sort of
sits it it's a really neat satellite
it's it's a Lagrange point so basically
garage point yeah that's very cool so a
new channel that kind of went up that
you can kind of see at global scale you
know it's weird the first time that we
saw a picture of the planet is this
flame famous blue dot picture that your
brand's pushed to NASA and this wasn't
that long ago right this was in the 60s
that the blue dot picture came out and
now we have all these satellites going
up all these satellites who recorded
data for years now it's time to go do
something with it like it's very
inspiring to see that blue dot picture
because it puts the world into
perspective yeah but it still doesn't
give you any information about what's
going on down there so now is the time
we've got the computing resources to do
it we have the machine intelligence now
to go analyze this stuff at true scale
so if ever there's a time to go built
well and I think that there's a
planetary reason to do so right like we
need to understand what we're
in much much more detail so become how I
sir
all those things together I mean now is
the time now is the time yeah yeah and
then it's you see so then you actually
used Amazon Web Services and and for all
this crazy amount of data refining of
petabytes of data like in parallel
processing like 40,000 cores yeah so
yeah we did something really cool this
week so there's a top 500 list of
supercomputers that comes out every six
months and what we did was we wanted to
prove that we could get on that list in
the cloud so we did so we're number 136
in the world but it's really funky
because what the way we did it was
without any help from Amazon basically
like just swiping a credit card so this
is truly just commodity hardware
commodity processing we were able to get
one point nine two six petaflop s-- out
of this cluster so it's really neat if
you look at the entry on the top 500
list it says Descartes Labs but the
underlying hardware isn't a Cray
computer or an IBM computer or Dell
computer this is you know Amazon East
one ace like some cluster in an
anomalous place in the East Coast and
that's really mean because I think it
means that a you can suite you don't
need to spend twenty plus million
dollars on a supercomputer and go rent
it for thousands of dollars if you need
to need to spin one up and I think I
think we broke the list right like okay
you can imagine for the next list
there'll be a lot of a lot of teams to
say hey I want to be I want to be on the
list too and I guess I could just do it
on Amazon so I bet there's gonna be a
bunch of the next list and that'll cause
them to ask some questions democratizing
high performance computing is critical
to that digital twins simulation the
conversation we were having for
healthcare for the planetary simulations
for all the type of stuff yeah it's it
used to be the compute was really the
only people that had access to that
level of computing resources were large
companies and large governments and now
that we've democratized that it means
that compute is everywhere I mean you
the the phone that you have right is a
pretty powerful computer but when we can
do things like build a true
supercomputer in the cloud it means that
you can run simulation at scale
you think about the early supercomputer
is one of the reasons that we built them
was to simulate things like nuclear
weapons right so after the test ban
treaty in the 60s we wanted to make sure
that these things still work so there
was a lot of simulation work done in
early supercomputers and this is true
for things like weather modeling right
that you want to do at scale so this
isn't just an academic exercise of
spinning up supercomputers in the cloud
even though it's pretty cool it really
is critical to just bring these
resources to a much broader set of
people yep and the company decart labs
is named after Rene Dakar yep who
actually you were you know teaching me
about this a little bit earlier but his
there's so many things here it's not
only the like I think therefore I am but
it's also things like connecting
arithmetic in geometry you're just
crucial for calculus he has some other
really profound things like refusing to
accept authority of previous
philosophers saying things like I will
write on the stop because if no one had
written on these matters before like I
love that stuff that if a very
accessible beautiful work of philosophy
is Descartes meditations on First
Philosophy his sort of primary work and
he writes it in a very conversational
tone and he asks you to come on the
journey with him it's a thought
experiment so in the early meditations
he starts to think about what he knows
and he goes through this great thought
experiment and he looks at wax and he
asked whether the candle is what he
knows and it melts and it's like is that
the same material so he brings you on
this journey
with him and it's really just a
beautiful piece of literature a
beautiful piece of philosophy there's
the man himself yeah so just an
incredibly important human being in that
he separates mind and body so the mind
is the thinking thing and it experiences
the world one of the things he was
trying to do with the meditations was
make science safe in the church it was
one of his primary goals is to separate
knowledge from God so mind and body
proceeded from God in the meditations
and the reason he was doing this was to
try to make science safe from the church
so yeah he was just a towering figure
and and one of my great heroes so it's
cool to have a company named after yeah
yeah yeah and similar with like Tesla
Nikola Tesla right and the same thing
like the car labs now we have that I
liked I loved it I loved the work yeah
science safe from the truth from the
church yeah well and and again so
Cartesian coordinate system is where a
lot of people experience him so like X&Y
coordinate system which is how we mapped
our planet with longitude and latitude
so that you can be able to say cool
things like we are at this specific I I
would love to say that the reason that
we chose the name Descartes was all
these principal things like XY
coordinate system it also decart means
maps in french cart means map yeah but
really it was I was looking at a bunch
of URLs one night and realized that a
lot of the names that we thought about
choosing weren't available and Descartes
Labs was available the URL was available
and the Twitter handle was available so
I called it done but yeah it's a great
it's a great name it's very respectable
yeah name because anything else that
you'd really could potentially come up
with would potentially like pigeonhole
you into something but Dakar labs keeps
you really like wide open he's a really
broad thinker and I think you know we
were inspired by great scientist by
great thinkers so to have him as our
namesake it's pretty cool I have a
couple quick questions on the way out do
you think that were in a simulation
I mean I always think that's a I don't
like questions like that where I like
them as thought experiments but I'm not
sure what sort of answer you want there
I mean you sort of have to define
simulation and I think by any reasonable
definition of simulation that we would
agree upon the answer is probably yes I
don't know what that gains us right
because if you can't if you have no
epistemic knowledge of who is creating
that simulation
and how it's being created I'm not sure
that the knowledge of being in a
simulation is very useful or applicable
which we may gain that knowledge the
time now that's interesting right it's
all about epistemic access so like do
you have the ability to go to go answer
this question is is it a question that
you can pose and get a reasonable
scientific answer yes or no but yeah I
actually do think we'd probably live in
a simulation I think again it's it's
simulations all the way up and all the
way down yeah I mean we're gonna have to
deal with this soon because we're gonna
start simulating you many things
especially civilizations universes all
the type of stuff and then the G's a
bottle and we better understand
ourselves and we're able to tweak
variables and play with which is kind of
what we're potentially already in so I
mean yeah the matrix is one of the most
important like philosophy
like if you think about when I started
studying philosophy was also right
around the release of the matrix which
is just as like mind-blowing movie when
you first see if yes and it really makes
you wonder where does that simulation
end and let's ask the very last question
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world the Sangre de Cristo Mountains
right by Santa Fe New Mexico yeah you
know I haven't been but neither there
five years now five years and I tell you
I have a deep personal relationship with
those mountains as you know I it's not
just there's raw beauty in a lot of
different places but for me beauty is
also about connection and I've hiked
those mountains a lot of times I've just
spent a lot of time thinking and being
up there and they're just wandering I'm
sounding like a total hippie right now
but they're wonderfully welcoming yeah
and I miss them when I'm I'm not close
and I think they miss me a little bit
yeah to say sometime and I can we would
love that take you up to my friend the
Sangre de Cristo's means blood of Christ
because as the Sun sets especially
during the summer the
give this beautiful red purple hue over
the mountain oh cool cool that's where
it comes from Sangre de Cristo yes
that's interesting
nice yeah definitely yes please and it's
also potentially another beautiful thing
to have people go and how many people
even know the Rockies extend themselves
down to Santa Fe New Mexico like this I
sure didn't yeah sure die should don't I
need to go and yeah and and enjoy that
and connect with it spiritually decart
labs doing incredible work mark you have
been a major role model for us in the
space where like you're really thinking
on some visionary stuff here with
stacking all of these different optical
radar all these different layers of
understanding deforestation
understanding tree counts all this kind
of crazy stuff digital twins data
refineries I mean you're like we're
really excited we'll have to do an
update from you yeah we'd love to hear
the update from you soon so keep us in
mind when you come back through the area
there's still a lot to understand about
what you guys are doing so keep up the
good work we're all counting on you
thank you this has been a lot of fun I'm
glad you had a good time right thanks
for coming thanks sir
we appreciate it thank you
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on the episode and let us know what
you're thinking also check out the links
check out all those links to cart
labs.com Twitter on decart labs as well
as the medium and also Marc's Twitter
philosophy geek check those out everyone
and also have more conversations with
your friends your family's co-workers
people online on social media about the
importance of digital twins about
satellite imagery about the future with
sensing technologies and analyzing all
the data and refining it also shout-out
to Ron vargas our producer and director
thank you very much Ronnie and also
support the artists entrepreneurs the
organizations around the world that you
believe in support simulation our links
are below our patreon our cryptocurrency
link our PayPal link support us help us
grow as well and go and build the future
everyone if you want to you can make
cool thought-provoking merch not wearing
one of the shirts right now but that
link is below so you can design merch
and get paid for it check out that link
build the future everyone manifest those
dreams into the world thanks for tuning
in and we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]